[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
PETE LAPAGE: Well, welcome
everybody.
Kind of a fun day, a special
day for the Chrome Apps
Hangout today.
We have many of our Chrome
folks here, in
Mountain View, with us.
To my right, we've
got Paul Kinlan.
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
PETE LAPAGE: Paul wasn't with
us last week but is going to
be joining us regularly.
Paul?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I
was on vacation.
So I had a nice time off,
relaxed in the British sun.
PETE LAPAGE: Ooh, the British
sun, is that different than
the Brazilian sun or
the American sun?
PAUL KINLAN: It's
a little bit--
RENATO DIAS: Definitely.
PETE LAPAGE: Do you want
to introduce yourself?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, so
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer at Google,
working on Chrome Apps and
also Web Intents.
I have to keep saying this
every single time I do a
presentation.
PETE LAPAGE: I thought you
weren't allowed to say Web
Intents anymore though?
PAUL KINLAN: Oh yeah, It's
Stnetni Bew, isn't it?
PETE LAPAGE: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: We say Stnetni
Bew, which is Web Intents
backwards, but anyway.
Yeah, I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm developer advocate
at Google.
I'm just here in Mountain
View for the week.
PETE LAPAGE: Awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: So yeah, I thought
I'd come and say hello
to all you guys.
And let's talk about some
Chrome Apps things.
PETE LAPAGE: Cool Awesome.
And we also have Renato.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, I'm a
developer program engineer for
Chrome Apps.
And this is the second session
I've participated in.
And hopefully, we'll
have several
others, many other APIs.
PAUL KINLAN: Apparently, I'm
just hear for the banter,
which when I was asked to come
along for this, I said, why am
I going to be a Star Wars
character, one of those big
woolly mammoths?
And then I realized I'm here
for the funny conversation.
PETE LAPAGE: Yes, well,
there's that, too.
PAUL KINLAN: I've been preparing
that joke all week.
PETE LAPAGE: Thanks very much.
We'll be here next week, too.
We also have Paul Lewis
joining us.
Paul, do you want to say, hi,
and introduce yourself?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
hi, from London.
I'm Paul Lewis, a developer
programs engineer also on the
Chrome team, Chrome Apps.
And I also look at GPU and
performance stuff as well, but
primarily today, Chrome Apps.
PETE LAPAGE: So I'm
Pete LaPage.
I'm a developer advocate on the
Chrome team, working on
Chrome Apps and Chrome Mobile
and all sorts of really cool
Chrome stuff.
We've got a pretty exciting
show this week.
Last week, we gave you the
introduction to Chrome Apps.
We talked about, hey,
what are they?
How do they work?
We showed you some samples.
We showed you some cool stuff
on how you can get started.
This week we're going to dive
into some of the recent
changes as well as we're going
to build the Hello World and
take it into a little bit of a
Hello Galaxy sample and show
you some of the things that
are available with the
Windowing API.
Got to refer back to
your wookie joke.
Well, I guess it wasn't a wookie
joke, but banter joke.
PAUL KINLAN: I was looking
at Wookiepedia today.
PETE LAPAGE: Oh, there you go.
PAUL KINLAN: Just
to make sure.
I just realized as well, looking
at the camera as well,
I'm the only one who is
color coordinated.
I have the blue Chrome
logo as my T-shirt.
PETE LAPAGE: Well, I've got
the blue Chrome logo.
I've got a stripe.
Next time, I'll try better.
So with that, why don't we pass
it over to Renato, who is
going to talk about some of the
recent changes this week.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, this week
we had a breaking change on
the way you launch
a new window.
And previously, you launched
a window using the Chrome
experimental app API.
And this is, as it says in
the menu, experimental.
And after we had a few weeks
of feedback from you, we
transformed this API to
an app runtime API.
And it's not experimental
anymore.
So you should not expect that
many changes on this API
practical area.
PETE LAPAGE: So that's
a really good point.
Many of these APIs right now
are under the experimental,
which means they're
going to change.
And so, when they're going to
change, you just sort of have
to be a little bit
aware of that.
And at some point, they'll
come out of that
experimental state.
RENATO DIAS: Exactly.
PETE LAPAGE: And what does it
mean when they come out of
that experimental state?
PAUL KINLAN: It means they're
relatively set in stone.
Obviously nothing is completely
set in stone.
But the general idea is
that we're pretty
happy with this API.
We've got hold of the developer
feedback, and we're
pretty confident that it's not
going to change that much.
So it's like a little bit more
confidence that it's going to
be stable for the foreseeable
future or the near foreseeable
future at least.
RENATO DIAS: And talking
about window, we
also have a new feature.
It's not a breaking change.
But it's really cool, indeed,
where you can specify that
your window is Chromeless.
Chromeless means it
has no title bar.
And you have control of all the
UI of your application.
For this specifically, it is
still being developed.
PETE LAPAGE: So if it's under
development, it's probably
under the experimental API?
RENATO DIAS: Exactly.
PETE LAPAGE: So we need
to remember that.
It may change.
And we want your feedback.
If it's under experimental,
we want to hear from you.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, exactly.
Please, for all the APIs,
specifically for experimental
APIs, go to the Chromium
Apps forum.
We are there.
We answer any questions there.
And we really want to
hear your feedback.
For this frameless window, what
it means to be frameless,
it means basically for comparing
to the actual framed
window, we have a title bar, and
we have Close buttons and
Minimize buttons.
For the frameless windows, it's
just a window where you
draw on any part of it.
It brings a problem, because you
need part of your window
to be draggable, and you also
need a close button.
And we all are working on this,
specifically on the
draggable and on the
default title bar.
But for now, you can already
create a frameless window on
some platforms.
And Paul Lewis will show
you an example of that.
Paul?
PETE LAPAGE: Paul, why don't
you start off with a little
bit of a Hello World.
PAUL LEWIS: Before I do that,
I'm going to just quickly show
you this frameless window,
which I've got open here.
So this is on the Chrome app
samples GitHub repro.
So get the source code
for this right now.
PETE LAPAGE: So that's the
GitHub repro, which we've got
a URL for that, which
we'll show in a sec.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, And you see
that the window that it's
launched has nothing other
than the content.
So it's exactly as
Renato said.
We haven't got any
close buttons.
We haven't got anything else.
And if I check this box over
here, it introduces a title
bar, which means I can
now drag this around.
I can't drag using
anything else.
We have top and bottom.
PETE LAPAGE: Now are
those customizable?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I believe
they're completely within the
developer's control as to what
they want to put there.
PETE LAPAGE: Very cool.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, total
control over
how your window looks.
And then a close
button as well.
So that's a quick
look at that.
PAUL KINLAN: They look like
the widgets, don't they?
Do you know, like the little
notepad widgets with all the
little stickies and all
that type of stuff.
It's kind of cool the things
that you could do with that.
It's pretty cool, I think.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
So what I'm going to do is I was
just going to go through
the process of creating
Hello World.
And so you guys hopefully
can see what
I've got on my screen.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to step through
creating, as I said,
a Hello World app.
I just talk through the
various parts of it.
Guys, if you've got any
questions as I'm going, just
feel free to shout.
So the first thing that we
need is a manifest, which
basically tells Chrome about
the app, thus a JSON file.
So we'll start out with that.
And we will call it
manifest.json.
We need a "t" on the
end of that.
PETE LAPAGE: I kind of feel like
we should be doing the
Muppet thing.
We're the old guys, sitting up
on the top of the thing with
Muppets and making the
crazy comments.
PAUL LEWIS: I think you guys
would make fantastic Muppets,
for what it's worth.
PAUL KINLAN: I was going to
try and do a Fozzy Bear
impression.
Awww!
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
PETE LAPAGE: Paul, why
don't you keep going.
PAUL KINLAN: We'll be quiet.
PETE LAPAGE: The peanut gallery
will now shut up.
PAUL LEWIS: So far, I've
got two properties.
And the manifest version is what
tells Chrome that this is
going to be a packaged
app, Version 2.
Version 1, which is the next
property that I've got, it
actually says this is the
version of the app.
So if you update that to 1or
1.1 or something like that,
that's what you put there.
And the name of the app-- let me
put that in keys-- which is
going to be Hello World.
We talked about this
last time.
We tell Chrome that we want
to run this as an app.
And the background script
that we want to
run is going to be--
get this right--
main.js.
And this is the script that
runs in the background.
It's like the hub of all our
app's communication.
So it's what's actually going
to be responsible for
launching the windows.
It would be listening for the
on-launched event, which is
the one that Renato just
told you has changed.
So this is the manifest.
And the next file that
we create is
going to be this main.js.
PETE LAPAGE: Now, can I just
ask a quick question?
You said it has to be main.js.
Can it be like pete.js or
fred.js, as long as it's just
something .js?
PAUL LEWIS: You're telling
Chrome here what the script is
that you want to use as
the background script.
So you can call it anything
you like.
Conventions says it might
be something like main.
PETE LAPAGE: Main, maybe app.js,
something like that.
PAUL LEWIS: Exactly.
Something that is indicative
of the role
it's playing, I guess.
So new file.
PAUL KINLAN: And I'd say the
really cool thing there as
well is you can actually have
multiple main files in that
list as well.
So you can break up your
applications--
PETE LAPAGE: Oh, cool!
Yeah, and because you're not
actually pulling files down
over the internet, there's no
latency or delay or anything,
it's just like that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So this is
actually an array.
So it's just an array with
a single item in it.
So the main.js, as I say, this
is the hook of the app.
This is the thing that Chrome is
running in the background.
So the first thing we want to do
is we want to-- and this on
the new namespace, which
is the new API, the
chrome.app.runtime.
And we want to attach a listener
to the on-launched
event, which is what we want
Chrome to do whenever we
actually kick off the app.
So here we go.
And I throw a function
in there.
That always works.
And inside that, we're going
to say, chome.app.window,
which is one of our new APIs.
Create, and we want
to create--
the first thing we do is we tell
which HTML file we want
it to load.
And then we give it an object
with a load of properties
there which specify
things like width.
I won't add it to this, but you
could, if you wanted to,
add the new frame None, which
is exactly how you get that
frameless window.
So if you want to create a
frameless window, you add the
frame None property to when you
create a window, and that
will let you do that.
So now I've got a main.js
and the manifest.
But the last thing I need at
this stage is the index, which
is going to be what we actually
try and load up.
PETE LAPAGE: Now again,
you can use any
file name you want.
You don't have to
call it Index.
You could call it,
MyMainApp.html.
PAUL LEWIS: Exactly.
And I'm just making life
simple for myself.
I'm just going to call
it, say, Hello World.
So that's it.
That's about all you
need to actually
create a packaged app.
So hopefully now, if
I go over here--
and I'm in Canary.
I've enabled the experimental
APIs and all those kinds of
things we talked about
last time.
And you can see, I've got Hello
World here that I'm
going to try and
load unpacked.
And all being well,
it's added itself.
Yay!
So now, if I go over here and
I click on this, I get my
window with Hello World in.
So that's all working.
That's exactly--
PETE LAPAGE: And it opens the
size that you said that you
want it to open because you
didn't say No Frame.
It still got the
normal things.
And you can drag it around, just
like you normally would
any other application
window, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Exactly.
So at this stage, it's like
these are almost things that
you'd expect from a web
app so that the
window is slightly different.
But one of the things that you
can do, we mentioned before,
is the Windowing API, which is
new controls that you've never
had before for handling
windows.
So I'm going to close
this down.
And I'm going to go
back to my source.
I'm going to add in a button.
And I'm going to give it
something descriptive, because
I'm helpful like that.
And I'm going to make
mention of a script.
And I'm just going to
call this app.js.
Again, you don't have
to call it--
PETE LAPAGE: So why not just
put the script inline?
PAUL LEWIS: Now, we will
talk about this.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: I'm glad you brought
it up now, though.
There are Content Security
Policies.
There are restrictions
on scripts.
And we'll talk about this
in a little bit.
One of the restrictions right
now is that you can't put
inline scripts in place.
This is supposed to protect your
app from injections and
cross-site scripts and those
kinds of attacks.
So I'm bouncing this script that
I need out to this app.js
file, which I'll go ahead
and make now--
app.js.
And I'm just going to spit up
a little bit of code here.
All being well, I'll immediately
invoke function
expression.
So what I want to do is I want
to grab my button from my
HTML, and I want to add
a click handler.
So adding that listener,
click.
And when you click it, what I'd
like to do is I would like
to call
chrome.app.window.minimize.
Now this is not something you
can normally do with a window.
You can only tell the browser,
hey, I'd like you to minimize
the window.
And then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to set a timeout,
where I'm going to say, OK,
well, after about 4 seconds,
chrome.app.window.restore.
So not only can you
minimize windows,
you can restore windows.
PETE LAPAGE: Sweet!
PAUL LEWIS: So all being well
now, if I go back to here and
launch this, I should have
a Minimize button.
And if this works, there
we go, minimized.
And after a few seconds,
if the set-timer
works, there it goes.
It's back.
The window has come back up.
PETE LAPAGE: Very nice!
PAUL LEWIS: So these kind of
capabilities and more, you now
have available to you through
the Windowing API.
And there are tons of
APIs like this, and
they're so much fun.
And you see how simple
that was.
That was just two lines of code
for Minimize and Restore.
So there we go.
PETE LAPAGE: Excellent!
So there's a whole Windowing API
set of instructions that
folks can go have a look that
allow you to minimize,
maximize, restore.
What else is in there?
PAUL LEWIS: There's
resizing, moving.
But there is a sample in the
Chrome sample where one window
is set to mimic its sibling,
which is quite interesting.
So you can do quite a lot of
complex logic with these,
where you could have conceivably
panel windows,
especially with the frameless.
So if you're making an app with
a main window and you
wanted panels to snap to the
screen edges and things like,
you could totally aim for that
kind of thing with these APIs.
PETE LAPAGE: OK.
PAUL LEWIS: All right?
PETE LAPAGE: Awesome.
Well, thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
PETE LAPAGE: Yeah.
All right, well, we started to
talk about that whole Content
Security Policy bit.
Content Security Policy, I
think, is something that's
really interesting and will
really help protect
applications from a certain
set of vulnerabilities.
Paul, do you want to tell us a
little bit more about Content
Security Policy?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so Content
Security Policy is quite
interesting.
I say interesting.
Actually, it is interesting.
I did have a full head of
hair before I started
messing with it.
And now--
sorry, it's a bad joke.
PAUL LEWIS: Believe me, I know
this stuff, my friend.
PAUL KINLAN: So Content Security
Policy is basically a
framework that is designed to
mitigate the risks of people
injecting code directly
into your web page.
As you know, with HTML and
JavaScript, it's actually
pretty easy, unfortunately, to
cross-site script on different
sites, just by injecting
malformed HTML into a page or
any kind of malformed
content into a page.
And when you think about the
capabilities that these
applications have, whether
it's access to USB or
Bluetooth--
PETE LAPAGE: They have
advanced access.
They have things that normal
web apps, normal websites
don't have access to.
PAUL KINLAN: Exactly right.
So even things like Chrome
Synchronized Storage, for
instance, you don't want to
basically get people injecting
a small piece of JavaScript or
HTML inside your application.
PETE LAPAGE: Oh, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And
then kind of--
I'm not saying take over the
system, but do things that the
user didn't expect on the
system from that single
application.
So Content Security Policy is
designed to restrict the types
of things that people could do
inside your application in the
sense of executing arbitrary
JavaScript and HTML.
So some of the things we've seen
before and Paul mentioned
it earlier on was you're not
allowed to have any inline
JavaScript inside the page.
That's like on-click, so a
button on-click, for instance,
which Paul didn't do--
PETE LAPAGE: Oh, yeah, so if
actually put on-click inside
the button.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
you can't put the
JavaScript inside there.
It's pretty to hijack that if
you didn't have Content
Security Policy in place.
And then likewise, inline script
elements, you can't
have them inside the page.
They have to be inside a
separate artifact that's
inside the Chrome package,
for instance.
So they're just some of
the basic things.
There are other things as well
that you find in Chrome
packaged applications at least
that is enforced by the
Content Security Policy is
that you can't directly
reference external resources.
PETE LAPAGE: Oh.
OK, so I couldn't necessarily
say, hey, I want to go grab
some fonts from TypeKit or
something like that.
PAUL KINLAN: The fonts
are interesting.
I believe not at the moment.
But there are other
things as well.
You can't load JavaScript from
arbitrary sources outside your
application.
Obviously, you can do
cross-domain XML HTTP requests.
So we've always had the ability
in Chrome Apps be able
to specify a white-listed set
of sites, for instance, like
your application can XML
HTTP request to.
And then you can bring
the content in.
But it has to be brought in
and maintained and locally
stored inside your
application.
PAUL LEWIS: This is why we were
talking about last time,
and I think it's worth
saying again, that
it's offline first.
And you really do you need to
think about those terms.
PAUL KINLAN: Exactly right.
I mean, one of the things that
you find as well is that
images, for instance, you are
not really supposed to
reference images that are
normally structural, for
instance, remotely.
So what we're trying to do is
get developers to make sure
that their applications, all
that images that they need,
are referenced locally.
This introduces some
complexities.
You might have to download the
image, store it locally inside
the applications local file
system API or the local file
system sandbox and then
reference from there.
And we've got, actually,
some great examples.
So there is one news reader
application, which basically
fetches data from the Google
News RSS feeds, but it stores
all the RSS feeds in
local storage.
And it does a XML HTTP request
to go out, brings it into
local storage.
And then that makes sure that
the actual content that you've
requested is available
regardless of whether you're
online or not.
It's pretty interesting how
you're going to get around
this at the moment.
But it's there primarily
as a protection thing.
Secondary as well is
to make sure these
applications work offline.
There are two exceptions, video
and audio, where you
might want to stream the audio
in off the web, if you're
doing a streaming-based
audio player.
You might want to bring that in
off the web and just have
access to that.
And interestingly as well, in
our GitHub account, we've also
got a demonstration
that does that.
So basically it goes out, and
you can stream video from,
say, your local network
into your application.
PETE LAPAGE: And those are on
the Chrome App samples?
PAUL KINLAN: It's a separate
repository on the Google
Chrome GitHub user account.
I believe it's called
Video Player.
We can share the link
later as well.
But essentially, you can go off,
connect to your remote
networks, your home networks,
stream the video in, and then
just kind of say, well, you
know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to save this for
later, bring it in, store it
in your local file system API,
and then play it back offline.
So that's interesting.
There's two other little
bits as well.
You're not allowed to
do dynamic code
execution as well in CSP.
So that basically removes
the EVAL essentially.
PETE LAPAGE: Yeah,
EVAL, EVAL evil.
PAUL KINLAN: Which does cause
some issues in the sense of a
lot of template and libraries
have been built to basically
build up a function dynamically
based off the
template structure and then
execute it as you build the
template out.
There are workarounds for it.
You can either precompile
a template.
So things like Handlebars,
for instance.
You can use Handlebars to
precompile a template.
I mean, there's not a lot
of people who actually
dynamically compile templates
on the fly anyway.
It's a convenience
thing normally.
But essentially, what you'll
try and do is you will just
compile it and include it inside
your application, and
it works absolutely fine.
It works brilliantly.
And then there's other template
frameworks, things
like Angular.
Sorry, it's not a template
framework.
But Angular has got the
ability to build these
templates on the fly, because
it's more of a DOM-based
structure anyway.
So it doesn't go off and
execute a new function.
It can just do it.
PETE LAPAGE: It just does it.
PAUL KINLAN: Because it builds
the structure of the DOM up
automatically.
So CSP does introduce
this restriction.
We think it's a good
restrictions for users.
It's a little bit awkward for
developers in the fact that
you have to maybe retool
it a little bit.
But it's not too hard
to get around.
PETE LAPAGE: It sounds like
there's going to be some
rethinking in terms of there
were things we used to do that
could sometimes allows
cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities or security
vulnerabilities.
And now these things put us
into a more strict way of
writing our code but will also
help us to make sure that we
write better code.
And that's important.
I want to write better
code every day.
I want to make sure that I'm not
exposing my users to like,
oops, sorry, lost some
information for you.
Oops.
PAUL KINLAN: If you look on
the developers.chrome--
is it developer.chrome or
developers.chrome.com/apps--
we actually include a list of
frameworks we know to work
with CSP and workarounds
as well.
The interesting thing if you're
building a backbone-
based application, the default
template and library doesn't
work, which is the underscore
template and library, because
it builds a function
of a runtime and
then executes that.
Just use Handlebars for it.
RENATO DIAS: Talking about the
documentation, we are also
working on that page,
specifically.
And we will show some samples
of the most important or the
most used frameworks and how
to use it on packaged apps.
So in a few weeks, we will have
a more complete page with
more samples.
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, and this
goes out to the audience as
well, is if you're building
applications and testing
applications today and you find
that one of your template
and libraries or maybe a
framework doesn't work, please
let us know.
Just go on the Chromium
Apps Google group.
Email any of us directly.
I'm talking PaulKinlan@Google
or my Google+ page.
We'll feed that back to the team
and try and make those
things work.
PETE LAPAGE: Yeah, we definitely
want to hear about
the things that you're using,
the things that
you're running into.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, because it
shouldn't be hard to build
these applications.
And we find that it's not.
It's just a little bit of a
mind shift to get these
frameworks working.
PETE LAPAGE: And I think Mike
West on our team has written a
really great article on Content
Security Policy that's
up on HTML5 Rocks.
You can go check that out.
It's a great Content Security
Policy primer and how-to.
A really great article, it
helped a lot for me.
RENATO DIAS: There's one
specific situation on Chrome
packaged apps is that you cannot
relax the CSP rules.
So on extensions and
on websites, you
can white-list domains.
You can white-list specific
script source or image source.
In Chrome App package
apps, they are not--
PAUL KINLAN: It's basically
set to local packet.
Everything is pretty much set
to the local package.
RENATO DIAS: That is
very important.
PAUL KINLAN: You know you can
store an image in the file
system API.
You can directly reference it
like a normal image link.
It's fine.
It's just that you've got to
try and get the image into
your application as well,
whether that's zipping it up
or downloading it and
installing it later.
PETE LAPAGE: Now, Renato, when
we were talking earlier, you'd
talked about some of
the things beyond
CSP that have changed.
Do you want to talk a little bit
about that and some of the
things that developers
should know about?
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, I will walk
through some of the features.
Talking about the mindset change
that Paul mentioned,
there are few things that
doesn't make sense in the
context of an app.
And there are a few things that
for security reasons,
like CSP, were disabled
on purpose.
So you have the list of all
these disabled web features on
our documentation website.
We'll show you the link
in a few seconds.
Am I right about the link?
PETE LAPAGE: I think I
got it in yesterday.
I think I made it.
But if it's not, we'll
just put it in the
notes after the fact.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, absolutely.
I grouped those web
features by the
reason they are disabled.
So I will just walk through
them and explain quickly.
The first group is we have a
different flow, workflow, on
an app that makes sense on an
app and doesn't make sense on
the web, on the open web.
And these features, disabled
features, are for this group
is form submission.
It doesn't make sense to submit
a form to an XML server
for obvious reasons.
Because you can do that.
You can use a JavaScript to grab
the submit event and then
Ajax, use XML HTTP request to
submit that asynchronously.
You cannot use the APIs--
feel free to interrupt me.
PAUL KINLAN: On anything?
Well, can we get some
football in?
PETE LAPAGE: So you had a
fun flight yesterday?
Nah.
RENATO DIAS: The APIs to change
the browser Chrome, the
visual aspects of the browser
that are available on
extensions are not available
on the app for
obvious reasons also.
We also have some limits on
the navigation object.
If you open a link, the link
will open on a browser, not on
your web application.
This is very important, because
you don't want the
user to be disrupted by clicking
on links and get out
of your application.
PAUL KINLAN: Does this include
links internally as well,
internal to the app?
RENATO DIAS: No, it doesn't.
PAUL KINLAN: The window
will never change.
But I'm presuming you have to
manage and intercept the click
and then do it.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, this is
very important stuff.
We are working to
create samples.
Because most of the frameworks
that manage the navigation
process depends on the link.
When I mentioned this change on
the list of frameworks, we
also have a code for some of the
frameworks that depend on
that and how it is
going to be.
PAUL KINLAN: So how
to do hijacks.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, Exactly.
And the cookie--
PETE LAPAGE: Cookies?
Cookies?
RENATO DIAS: Where?
Where?
It's not lunchtime yet.
PETE LAPAGE: Darn.
RENATO DIAS: The document
cookies doesn't make sense in
a client-only environment.
Cookies are basically to send
information to the server and
if you're using a server
to generate
content for your client.
So also you can use OAuth
and other stuff, too, to
circumvent that.
Regarding safety and CSP,
we disabled Flash.
We disabled inline JavaScript
and the non-sandboxed plugins.
PAUL KINLAN: So we can still run
Native Client code, right?
RENATO DIAS: Pardon me?
PAUL KINLAN: We can still
run Native Client code?
RENATO DIAS: Yeah,
we can run NaCl.
We absolutely can run NaCl.
I think we have samples
for that also.
And the games we showed on the
Google I/O, they use NaCl.
It's pretty amazing.
We also cannot show
external resource.
We talked about that before.
And for this synchronous nature
of some of the web
features, we have disabled them,
because it stops the
flow of the JavaScript
execution.
And those are the model
dialogues, like Alert,
Confirm, the local storage, and
the synchronous Ajax, the
XML HTTP request.
PAUL KINLAN: So can we go into
local storage a little bit
more and tell us why--
things that you might
have to do?
RENATO DIAS: Yeah.
If you are using local storage,
you should be use the
indexed [INAUDIBLE] changer code
to index the [INAUDIBLE]
because it's asynchronous, and
it allows storing BLOBS and
storing objects.
You don't have to change
out your code, too.
PETE LAPAGE: But there's also
Chrome Sync with is, I think,
where you were getting at.
RENATO DIAS: Yeah, absolutely.
PETE LAPAGE: Which is cool.
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, it's
relatively like the local
storage API.
It's key value pair based.
The idea behind it is it tries
to be asynchronous.
One of the guiding
principals--
PETE LAPAGE: There
is two of them.
There's chrome.storage.local
and chrome.storage.sync.
PAUL KINLAN: Actually,
that's a good point.
So local is entirely local
to the application.
And the synchronized one--
PETE LAPAGE: So if I think of
chrome.storage.local, that's
almost identical to local
storage, in that everything
sits on my one computer, one
machine, doesn't go anywhere.
It's asynchronous versus
synchronous.
RENATO DIAS: And it allows
known strings.
PETE LAPAGE: So I can store--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETE LAPAGE: --true
objects in it.
So then with
chrome.storage.sync--
now, this is the one that I
go, this is kind of cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so the
chrome.storage.sync will allow
you to basically say, well, I've
got my app installed on
three different machines.
How do I get the settings
between those, for instance?
And it's just using the
synchronization framework
built into Chrome already to
make sure that those settings
and the data are replicated
across.
And there are a couple of events
that tell you when data
has arrived and all this
type of stuff as well.
So it's pretty cool.
It's relatively limited in
amount of data that can store
in it and the amount of
operations that you can do.
So right now, we're basically
trying to say if you've got
local application settings,
for instance, that's what
you'll store in the Chrome
Synchronized Storage.
Because that's one of the things
that everyone hates
about being on multiple machines
is that your basic
configuration is not
replicated across the machines.
PETE LAPAGE: And that's one of
the things I love about Chrome
is that I go to one computer,
to another computer, and
everything is just all shared.
PAUL KINLAN: You don't have
to use a developer.
You don't have to build
the infrastructure for
synchronization.
RENATO DIAS: And it's
all there for you.
PETE LAPAGE: Now, could I put
gigabytes worth of data into
Chrome Sync?
PAUL KINLAN: No, I think
it's limited to a
couple of hundred kilobytes.
PETE LAPAGE: So I couldn't
actually go and put
everything in there?
PAUL KINLAN: All your movies.
PETE LAPAGE: All my movies.
PAUL LEWIS: The documentation
does list the quotas.
So there's the limit on the
number of items, the item
size, and the number of requests
that you can make.
So make sure to check out
the documentation.
It lists those.
PETE LAPAGE: That's an important
thing to just keep
in mind, that you can't put
everything in there.
It's not like a big dump truck
that you can just shove
everything in.
The internet is a
bunch of tubes.
PAUL KINLAN: So can I just
actually preempt one of the
questions that we've got
on the Moderator?
PETE LAPAGE: In fact,
you know what?
PAUL KINLAN: Because it's
relevant to this.
PETE LAPAGE: Sure.
PAUL KINLAN: So we had a
question, quite early on in
the Moderator queue, which
basically said how do you
migrate your local storage
settings from your Chrome apps
to synchronized storage?
PETE LAPAGE: Oh,
good question.
PAUL KINLAN: It has to be
a manual taskk, right?
I say manual.
It's like a developer
manual task.
You have to have a step inside
your application, which
basically says migrate all these
local storage key value
pairs into Chrome's
local storage.
PETE LAPAGE: Will that
work though?
Because from within the
app, you don't have
access to local storage.
PETE LAPAGE: So this is actually
a really good point.
You got to remember is that
these apps aren't yet
available on the Chrome
Web Store.
So if you're going to do it now
with your packaged app or
extension and you've got them
stored in local storage, I
think Manifest Version
2 is fine for these.
You might want to start to think
about migrating your
application as opposed to
sitting in storage right now.
PETE LAPAGE: So if you've got a
packaged app with a Manifest
Version 1 today, you have access
to local storage and
you have access to Chrome Synced
storage, so you should
move it there.
So that way when you ship your
Manifest Version 2, your
updated Chrome packaged app,
it now has access to this.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
the theory.
PETE LAPAGE: Cool.
OK, that makes a
lot more sense.
And if you didn't see my hands,
I went like here to
here, and then from
here to here.
PAUL KINLAN: Or we could just
say the word "synchronize,"
and then we'd be fine.
PETE LAPAGE: That
would work, too.
So on that note, I want to
remind folks of the survey
that we're asking folks
to go and do.
That survey is what Chrome
APIs are you
most interested in?
What are the things you
want us to talk about?
We're going to plan our next
couple of Hangouts based on
the feedback we get from you.
We want to dive into
some of these APIs.
Today we talked a little bit
about the Windowing API.
But there's the USB.
There's Bluetooth.
There's serial.
There's networking.
There's all sorts
of cool APIs.
Tell us which ones you're most
interested in so that we can
try and really focus on
the ones you're most
interested in first.
And I think with that, we've got
a about five minutes, six
minutes left.
So let's go to the Moderator
and take a
couple of the questions.
PAUL KINLAN: It's changed quite
a bit, actually, since
we've started this.
So should we start from
the first one?
RENATO DIAS: The first
one is from Tim.
And he asks, "For enterprise,
some companies dislike
auto-updating apps.
Would it be possible to embed
a version of Chrome inside
your Chrome app?"
PAUL KINLAN: I think
the answer--
yeah, that's a hard,
good question.
RENATO DIAS: I think the
answer currently is no.
PAUL KINLAN: I think there
are device policies.
There are policies
for Chrome--
PETE LAPAGE: There are some
enterprise policies that, as
an enterprise, you can say
I do not want Chrome to
auto-update.
I want to manage the roll-out of
Chrome in my organization.
So once you do that, you should
be able to control how
that comes out.
RENATO DIAS: But I'm curious
if the question
is I want the Chrome--
PAUL KINLAN: Things like
Enterprise apps?
RENATO DIAS: The whole Chrome
runtime on the computer runs a
specific version, or if the
Chrome apps runs it different?
PAUL KINLAN: It's like, you
don't want Chrome to update.
And then if you don't want
Chrome to update, you've
probably got a very restrictive
policy about apps
updating as well.
I think you might be
able to control the
update policy for apps.
PETE LAPAGE: I believe you
may be able to do that.
If you're using Google Apps
dashboard and you're
installing your apps through
there, I believe you're right.
You can.
PAUL KINLAN: But if it's a
public app that you found on
the public web store,
essentially, I don't believe
you have any ability to control
that at the moment.
I don't know.
It's feedback that we get.
And I've heard it quite
a few times.
RENATO DIAS: Let's
go to the next.
It's from Russell.
"Apps and extensions have very
exciting features, bringing
new possibilities in being able
to personalize Chrome.
When using Chrome for Android,
however, it doesn't work.
Are they going to be added?
When can we write an app for
my phone?" We had this same
question last week, right?
PETE LAPAGE: Yeah, Paul, do
you want to go ahead?
PAUL LEWIS: I was going to say
some guy talked about this at
I/O. That's right, right?
PETE LAPAGE: Yep.
PAUL LEWIS: And the plan is that
we do want to bring all
these apps to mobile, to
all platforms, really.
It's about what we're trying to
do at the moment is get the
desktop story correct and make
sure that we are consistent
there and we iron
out any kinks.
And then we don't have a date
or time or anything, but we,
as I say, do plan
to roll it out.
It's just about getting that
right on the desktop first.
PETE LAPAGE: Yeah.
RENATO DIAS: Jake sent a lot of
good questions last week.
And this week, he also has
a very good question.
We would take the chance that
Paul Kinlan is here and would
be able to answer this.
PAUL KINLAN: Is this the
Open-With question?
RENATO DIAS: Yes.
PETE LAPAGE: Is this a
Stnetni Bew question?
PAUL KINLAN: It might be.
RENATO DIAS: Let's say that I
have implemented simple text
[INAUDIBLE] packaged
Chrome app.
Is there any way to expose this
app and open with context
menu, which shows up when a user
right-clicks on TXT files
in File Manager?"
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
RENATO DIAS: OK.
PETE LAPAGE: All right,
so the answer is yes.
Next question.
PAUL KINLAN: It's not quite
there just yet.
I mean, the intention--
to excuse the pun--
was to have your application--
thank you.
We need sound effects for--
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: The intention was
to basically say Web Intents
has got a view intent.
The user intends to do view
some content, essentially.
They don't particularly
intend to edit it or
do some other stuff.
They just want to view it.
And whilst we don't have it in
the platform just yet, with
the ability to say, look, I want
to be in the Open-With
for text files, that was the
goal I had quite early on with
this whole thing, was we've got
the ability to say I need
to view text files.
I need to view images.
And I need to view videos and
all this type of stuff.
Therefore, you should be able
to use the existing Web
Intents functionality to say
to the system I want to be
able to view these types--
my application can view
these types of files.
So when the user says, I want to
view it, like an image or a
video, your application
will be listed there.
I think we're a little bit away
from that, just getting
that in right now.
The goal is there to
do that, I think.
The general idea behind Web
Intents inside these platform
apps is it is like IPC basically
for these web
platform type of apps.
So the idea is that you might
be able to say, well, I need
to do some other different types
of actions, and your
applications will be
able to talk to
each other via Intents.
So the goal is there.
I don't think it's available
just yet.
PETE LAPAGE: But it's coming?
PAUL KINLAN: Well, if you look
at Chrome itself, I think in
the beta channel, it's got the
ability to view RSS feeds
inside an application.
So your application can say I
need view RSS or Atom feeds.
You'll see it today.
We've got a couple
of extensions.
I think Wordpress has
got an extension.
And RSS Feed Viewer, he's had
like 60,000 installs in week
just from this piece
of technology.
But the idea behind that is you
say, I need to view an RSS
feed, You can open in
a viewer inside your
application of choice.
PETE LAPAGE: So I think
we have time
for one more question.
So do we want grab one more?
PAUL KINLAN: Well, actually,
there's one here. "Can I make
a window always on
top?" By Marco.
Right now, no.
I believe you can't make a
window stay on top at all.
It's good piece of feedback that
we should give back to
the team, actually.
PETE LAPAGE: So we'll get
that back to the team.
But it's always helpful if you
guys go and file bugs on
Chromium bugs.
Because that way, not only do
we get the feedback to the
team, and they hear it from us,
but everybody else who's
watching today can go star that
issue and say, yeah, I
want that, too.
Don't add the comment that says
I want that, too, but
just star it so that the
engineering team sits there
and goes, oh wow, this really
is a popular thing.
So I think that's probably
about all the
time we have for today.
I want to thank these two for
being here and Paul for
joining us from London.
We'll be back next week, though
everybody is going to
be in their home location.
I'll be back in New York.
You're back in London.
RENATO DIAS: And I'm
back in Sao Paulo.
PETE LAPAGE: You're
in Sao Paulo.
So we're going to be coming to
you from all over the world.
PAUL KINLAN: Before we finish,
there's actually about 18 or
19 questions on the Moderator.
We only had three at the
start of this talk.
Is there anyway that we can just
start to answer some of
these questions?
PETE LAPAGE: Why don't we take
a stab at answering some of
these questions in the
setting responses in
the Moderator queue.
So we'll take a stab
to give you some
answers on some of these.
So have a look at the
Moderator queue for
this after the fact.
We'll try and get
some of the--
PAUL KINLAN: We've run
a little bit late.
I was doing the banter.
PETE LAPAGE: Well, with that,
guys, yep, exactly.
Paul's hiding his head.
I'm going to hide myself.
With that, thank
you very much.
We look forward to seeing you
next week, 9:00 AM Pacific,
noon Eastern, 5 o'clock
in London,
somewhere around the world.
Can't wait to see you.
Thanks everybody.
PAUL KINLAN: Bye.
RENATO DIAS: Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]